you mentioned a camera is the best
weapon
maybe just well you can't take out a
tank
right right but it's a good second
top top three
yeah i love the humor throughout this i
really i really appreciate it it's me
we're talking about such dark topics
yeah
it resets the mind in a way that allows
me to think so thank you
as a
as as a filmmaker
i almost want to talk about
the technical details
how how do you
choose to shoot stuff
again so maybe you can explain to me
i work with incredible folks
that care about
lenses and equipment
and so on
i tend to be somebody um
that just
wants to kind of
go as
like a gorilla shooting
like a um not not plan too much just go
with
uh gritty i'm trying to come up with
words that sound positive
do a positive spin on what i try to do
but like gritty
don't over plan
uh use like we had a big discussion if
you see this light yeah um it's it's on
a stand that's a very ghetto stand yeah
you need a sandbag on that man exactly
so no no see
no sandbag and and like the the stand is
actually bending under the weight of
that thing it could fall on us it could
fall won't reach us but it could but the
danger
live under that danger embrace that
danger
love it yeah um because that thing is
easier to transport than a heavier one
yeah sandbag that's extra weight so if
you keep like uh people tell me there's
the right way to do stuff like here's
these giant cases with all kinds of
padding for transporting stuff i
transport most of the equipment in a
garbage bag yeah so i i that's just a
preference because that's somehow
that chaos allows me to sit to ignore
all the stupidity of uh loving the
equipment and focusing on the story so
that said i've never shot anything
like worthwhile
like
uh there is power to the visual yeah
yeah like definitely and so
finding a certain angle a certain light
whether it's natural light or additional
artificial lighting
just capturing a tear capturing
um
when the person forgets themselves for a
moment and looks out into the distance
missing somebody thinking about somebody
all of those like moments you can
capture
a lens a camera can do magic with that
um i don't even know the question i'm
asking you but how
do
both technical and philosophical how do
you capture the visual power that you're
after
yeah
so so many of my films
i think
are built on the premise of access
right
built on this notion that um
the
the biggest hurdle
to the story is getting there
being there in the room or being there
on the boat
while the crisis is unfolding
and that access typically is really
nuanced and difficult to gain
and and then trust flows from that right
because usually it takes a long time to
gain that access
because that access is so hard fought
um it necessarily informs
how we film
right
to be in a room at sadaka hospital in
southern yemen i can't have five people
in that room
right i can't have a boom mic
over a scene
i want in creatively the opposite of
that as well so it's not just a
logistical question it's also a creative
question
to capture intimate moments where
families are dealing with suffering
children and dying children and and
caretaking is is active and ongoing all
the time
you don't want to interrupt that moment
and so that informs how i do things so
we go fleet and nimble and small
those are all really good words for
but but so it's logistical on the one
hand but it's also a creative choice
right so when we filmed hunger ward
two people were filming the entire film
right me and my director of photography
that was the two people in the room two
people in the room
yeah wow that's it the whole film right
we had a field producer as well in this
part of the country but in terms of
camera it's just two people and we're
doing everything and we have lenses
um
that you know are long enough that we
don't have to move to capture the film
so we can tuck into a corner sometimes
right
and so just what's long mean that means
they're standing farther away and they
can zoom lens it's not a prime lens so
it's not a fixed focal length right
because a fixed focal length you have to
move a lot more in order to capture
action with with a zoom lens um you know
maybe a 105 at the long end you know i
can tuck into a corner and just film
from 15 feet away instead of having to
get right up on someone right so you
you're less likely to interrupt the
scene
and and you can kind of become the fly
on the wall sometimes
so so you know i'm very intentional
about that piece of it so that we can we
can capture those vulnerable moments and
not interrupt them
that's really fascinating too because
the access
i don't often think about this but
that's probably true for me as well
um
part of the storytelling
is to be in the room
and that's the hard part yeah for me
most of my films that's the hardest part
actually as hard as hunger ward and
lifeboat were to film and 50 feet from
syria
the getting their piece of it for the
last two was much harder yeah and it's
also it's a it's a creative act
it's it's like i don't know if it is for
you but it's the kind of people you talk
to
it's uh
it's like how you live your life like
the kind of people i talk to right now
they steer the direction of my life and
steer the direction of things that i'll
film
so like it's not just like you're trying
to get access it's like
it's everything it's like it builds
it builds and builds and builds and
builds on itself yeah yeah
i mean part of the thing even saying you
know talking about some of these leaders
and conversations with them
it's almost like
staring your life into the direction of
the difficult
of like
taking the leap and
uh if you're a good human being
and a lot of people
know who you are as a human like not not
as a name but as really who you are yeah
that like putting that attention out
there it's somehow the world
opens doors where
the access becomes
the access that was once seemed
impossible
becomes possible and then all of that is
a creative journey to be in the room i
think that probably is i mean it's true
even for fiction films probably is like
everything that led to that like uh to
be in the room the journey to be in the
room and to shoot the scene
is maybe more important than the scene
itself
and like really focus on the creative
act of that yeah that's really
fascinating and especially i mean with a
documentary you get one take
yeah you can't say hey he's reset right
yeah yeah exactly god that is so
interesting as you were in some of the
most difficult
parts of the world
in the room with some of the most
difficult stories to be told
and yet
i think that's why i keep doing these
stories
right because
it's it's once you have that lived
experience for me
um
it's moving
it it moves me
to bear witness
to these
um
these these inspiring people under
difficult circumstances and and it you
know i can't come back to the u.s
afterwards
and you know
walk down the grocery aisle where
there's
50 different choices for canned peas
right and not
sort of
feel that live tension right that live
tension of the privilege
that i have here in the u.s and then i
have a choice about what to do with that
privilege right and the last thing i
want to do is start you know
doing stories about dandelions right
there's far more important things to do
on this very limited time that i have on
the planet and
you know i think that that um
that's catalytic for me like
i
feel that mortality each day
and my goal is to
is to tell as many of these stories
um
before i'm gone
you